IT'S TIME TO PLAY CHILL DOG OR
KILL DOG.
DOGS ARE SUPPOSEDLY MAN'S BEST
FRIEND, BUT IF REDDIT HAS TAUGHT
ME ANYTHING, IT'S THAT THE MAN
IS LYING TO US, MAN.
SURE, SOME PUPS HAVE YOUR BACK
WHEN YOU NEED IT, BUT OTHERS
WILL TURN ON YOU FASTER THAN YOU
CAN SAY "ATTACK PUG."
REMEMBER THIS CLASSIC VINE?
( PAPER RUSTLING )
( DOG BARKS )
>> Chris: YOU ALRIGHT.
>> I'M OKAY.
THANK YOU.
>> Chris: IT WAS JUST A VIDEO.
>> OKAY.
[LAUGHING]
>> Chris: JUST A VIDEO.
NOT REAL.
SO CUTE, SO SCARY, AND SUCH
GREAT COMEDIC TIMING FOR AN
ANIMAL THAT DOESN'T UNDERSTAND
WHY HIS BALLS HAVE BEEN TAKEN
AWAY.
SO, COMEDIANS, I'M GOING TO SHOW
YOU A PICTURE OF A POOCH, AND,
FOR 250 POINTS, I WANT YOU TO
TELL ME IF IT'S A CHILL DOG OR A
KILL DOG.
FIRST ONE, A RADIANT GOLDEN
RETRIEVER-- IS HE A CHILL DOG OR
KILL DOG?
HEATHER AN CAMPBELL.
>> I WILL SAY A KILL DOG.
Chris: I DON'T KNOW.
LET'S FIND OUT.
>> LOOK AT HIM, KILL DOG.
[LAUGHING]
>> KILLED IT.
>> KILL DOG.
Chris: SUPER CHILL IN THE
END.
IT WAS ALMOST LIKE, I CAN'T HELP
IT I'M SORRY.
REALLY SORRY.
NEXT UP THIS LOYAL LAB, CHILL
DOG OR KILL DOG.
LEATHER AN CAMPBELL.
>> CHILL DOG?
hris: LET'S FIND OUT.
>> IS IT THE SAME DOG?
>> AHHHH.
[LAUGHING]
>> Chris: I SWEAR TO DOG --
>> IT'S GOD BACKWARDS.
Chris: THIS DOG IS MY SPIRIT
ANIMAL FOR HOW I INTERACT WITH
THE INTERNET.
COME ON GUYS STOP [BEEP] ON ME.
NOW THESE UNLIKELY BEST FRIENDS.
>> YOU ARE A CHILL DOG.
Chris: CHILL DOG OR KILL DOG.
KNOW HE WILL?
>> DEFINITELY A KILL DOG.
Chris: LET'S FIND OUT.
>> DON'T BE SO SHORT.
[LAUGHING]
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT IS.
Chris: THAT'S --
>> THAT'S BOTH.
Chris: IT'S NOT VERY CHILL TO
TEA BAG A CAT.
THAT IS A KILL DOG.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
>> HE'S TRYING TO WARM --
>> YES.
Chris: I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S
WHAT HE'S TRYING TO DO.
>> THE CAT LOOKS LIKE A RUG.
Chris: YA.
>> HOW WAS HE SUPPOSE TO KNOW.
KREUFPL I DON'T KNOW.
>> CHILL.
hris: I'M INTERESTED TO SEE
HOW YOU CHILL IN YOUR LIFE.
>> Chris: WHY ARE YOU PUTTING
YOUR BUTT ON MY FACE.
>> YO, I'M CHILL.
Chris: MOVING ON.
THIS BEAUTIFUL BEAR DOG.
DOES HE CHILL OR KILL?
YES, DEREK.
>> THIS DOG IS CHILL.
Chris: LET'S FIND OUT.
>> AHHH.
Chris: YES.
BECAUSE -- GOD FORBID THE
[BEEP] FILMING THAT COULDN'T
STOP TO HELP THE CAT.
MAKE THE DOG DO IT.
FINALLY WE HAVE A PAIR OF PUPS.
A CHILL DOG OR A KILL DOG.
DEREK WATERS.
>> I HATE TO SAY IT THERE IS
GOING TO BE A KILL DOG.
>> Chris: ALRIGHT.
LET'S FIND OUT.
[LAUGHING]
>> Chris: THE CORRECT ANSWER WAS
BOTH.
YOU GET POINTS.